wir kommen zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt
hier an diesem mittwochnachmittag
es geht dabei auch unterstützung für die
geflüchteten aus der ukraine es gibt
zwei anträge mehr dazu in der debatte
jetzt zunächst die staatsministerien
beim bundeskanzler die beauftragte der
bundesregierung für migration
flüchtlinge und integration
aller barack obama japan ist wir sind
mitten in der umsetzung und wir liefern
unsere masterplan heißt machen machen
machen und das hätten wir auch 2015 und
danach gebraucht aber in den pakt in der
vergangenen legislatur gab es ein
innenminister der eingangs anderen
masterplan hatte er gesagt hat wir
brauchen obergrenzen irrsinnige asyl
verschärfungen und migration als mutter
aller probleme das war nicht gut und
heute gibt es eine koalition die es
besser macht die für mehr sport und
aspect arbeitet die deutschland endlich
als modernes einwanderungsland versteht
die weiß dass flüchtlinge seien kein
berufes wir gehen einen anderen einen
besseren weg und es ist gut wenn die
union diesen weg auch mitgehen möchte in
den ländern dazu lade ich sie herzlich
ein
heute ist ragt 84 knapp drei monate
russischer angriffskrieg wir geben allen
schutz die aus der ukraine viele frauen
kindern älteren shoah überlebenden und
drittstaatsangehörigen das geht die
bundesregierung gemeinsam mit den
ländern und kommunen an wir sorgen für
ein gutes ankommen und gute
unterbringungen wir sicher die
verteilung im bundesgebiet und das
registriert wird mit amtshilfe mit pick
stationen und dem neuen free system
beschützen frauen und mädchen hier sind
die sicherheitsbehörden sehr wachsam
hier ist der koordinierungskreis gegen
menschenhandel präsent an bahnhöfen und
in den unterkünften
wir stellen den paragraf 24
aufenthaltsgesetz längst die weichen
auch integration mit sicherem aufenthalt
mit deutsch lernen mit zugang zum
arbeitsmarkt ab tag eins und das hätten
wir 2015 aufgebracht gebraucht
und wir ermöglichen für menschen braucht
der ukraine ab dem ersten juni
leistungen nach sgb 2 und sgb 7 statt
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz dass es mal
ein meilenstein liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
uns geht es um teilhabe von anfang an
für kinder in kita und schule für
jugendliche in ausbildung und
hochschulen für frauen und männer am
arbeitsmarkt und klar ist auch der bund
muss finanziell unterstützen darum haben
wir die länder und kommunen entlastet
bei der coop bei den kosten bei der
unterkunft der kinderbetreuung oder
beschulung mit insgesamt zwei milliarden
euro im november schauen wir ob das
reicht dass es gemeinsam mit den ländern
vereinbart damit war auch
ministerpräsident wüst sehr
einverstanden liebe union auch beim
roundtable ukraine dandy den der
bundeskanzler und ich im april
ausgerichtet haben ebenso klar muss sein
es darf keine ungleichbehandlung geben
es kann zum beispiel nicht sein dass
internationale studierende die aus
derselben situation aus der ukraine
fliehen hier zu einem asylverfahren
gezogen sind darum ist es richtig dass
hamburg in ein vorläufiges
aufenthaltsrecht zur weiterführung ihres
studiums ausstellt wir brauchen genau
diese perspektiven wir sehen bei den
geflüchteten
aus der ukraine jetzt schon wie gut
integration von anfang an funktionieren
kann deshalb brauchen wir jetzt den
verabredet neuanfang der migration und
integrationspolitik keine arbeitsverbot
schluss mit kettenduldungen
integrationskurse für alle und für ihre
perspektiven für einen aufenthalt wir
stellen die menschen in den mittelpunkt
nicht sein status wir wollen menschen
fördern nicht frustrieren gemeinsam auf
augenhöhe das heißt integration da
steckt unser land und unseren
zusammenhalt herzlichen dank
vielen dank
aktuelle zahlen wie viele menschen
mittlerweile beispielsweise auch nach
deutschland geflüchtet sind sind immer
etwas schwierig sie wissen das ist ja
mit der registrierung nicht
vorgeschrieben beispielsweise erst 90
tage brauchen die flüchtlinge ja keine
visum die aus der ukraine kommen stand
mitte mai sind in deutschland
mittlerweile aber auch etwa 830.000
kriegsflüchtlinge aus der ukraine
registriert das geht den angaben zufolge
aus einer internen übersicht des
bundesweiten verteilt systems hervor
seit zwölf wochen frauen kinder und
jugendliche auf der flucht und seit
zwölf wochen machen machen machen vor
allen dingen ehrenamtliche in ganz
deutschland sie engagieren sich sie und
haben organisieren
hilfstransporte sie begleiten
geflüchtete auf ihrem weg in einen neuen
alltag und helfen vor ort und all diesen
ehrenamtlichen an allererster stelle
möchte ich an dieser stelle ein von
ganzem herzen danke sagen und
es braucht deutlich mehr was wissen wir
zumindest ungefähr laut angaben der
bundesregierung dass 400.000 geflüchtete
vor allen dingen frauen kinder und
jugendliche in deutschland sind was wir
sicher wissen weil die kmk mit der
vorsitze karen primär richtig gute
arbeit gemacht hat ist die genaue anzahl
der schülerinnen und schüler die
wöchentlich aktualisiert wird was wir
aber gar nicht wissen ist wie viele
kinder und jugendliche sich überhaupt in
deutschland aufhalten und wie viele von
denen heute ein betreuer eine betreuung
in anspruch nehmen und wie viele einen
betreuungsplatz in anspruch nehmen wolle
was wir brauchen und das sagen uns die
verbände und das sagen uns die
ehrenamtlichen dass sie vieles auf den
weg kriegen weil insbesondere die kinder
und jugendlichen jugendhilfe gut
aufgestellt ist quasi krisenerprobt ist
aber sie erzählen uns eben auch wo noch
handlungsbedarf besteht zwischen bund
ländern und kommunen also zusätzliches
personal muss gewonnen werden auch
ukrainische frauen eingebunden
abschlüsse und qualifikationen
leichter anerkannt werden wir brauchen
konkrete maßnahmen finanzielle
unterstützung bei der kinderbetreuung
einen ausbau der sprach kitas darüber
hinaus das ist unsere gemeinsame aufgabe
mit den ländern ein bedarfsorientiertes
unterstützungsprogramm für die
geflüchteten kinder und jugendlichen zum
beispiel durch den ausbau der frühen
hilfen auf den weg zu bringen aber auch
integrations und sprachkurse auszubauen
auszubauen das patenschaftsprogramm
menschen stärken menschen auszuweiten zu
diesen massnahmen sagen sie mit der
ablehnung unseres plans nein wir werden
an unseren forderungen festhalten und
ziehen die bereinigungssitzung des
haushaltes morgen einging und
entsprechend finanziell hinterlegen ich
danke allen die daran mitgewirkt haben
und vor allen dingen allen
ehrenamtlichen vielen dank silvia war
das für die unionsfraktion ja die beiden
anträge die dieser debatte zu grunde
liegen also jener der cdu csu fraktion
auch jener der linksfraktion die stammen
von anfang april mittlerweile ist
einiges geschehen villa breher für die
union sagt zumindest nicht genug was
sagen die grünen filiz polat jetzt
von cdu und csu war schon bei seiner
ersten lesung überholt daran hat sich
bis heute nichts geändert im gegenteil
an april beklagten sie hier stillstand
planlosigkeit hebräer sie haben das
wieder getan bei der bewältigung der
schrecklichsten flucht krise in europa
seit ende des zweiten weltkrieges und
das wohlgemerkt wenige stunden nachdem
bund und länder auch ihre länder sich
auf ein vorausschauendes und ein
pragmatisches paket zur aufnahme von
geflüchteten aus der ukraine verständigt
hatten nicht auf der höhe der zeit sind
also sie nicht etwa die bundesregierung
oder die bundesländer und im übrigen
auch nicht die kommunen meine damen und
herren
die angestaubte antrag inklusive einem
kurzen forderung und mängelliste war
schon war und ist schon längst in beiden
teilen abgearbeitet das hat
staatsministerin frau anna bali radovan
gerade erläutert dabei verehrte
kolleginnen aus der union geht es
nämlich auch anders geben sie nicht nur
vor sie hätten plötzlich ein herz für
geflüchtete entdeckt sondern handeln sie
auch so
nehmen sie sich gerne ein beispiel an
ihren kieler parteifreund daniel günther
der gegenentwurf in der
flüchtlingspolitik zu ihrem
fraktionschef märz eine fortschrittliche
an den menschen ausgerichtete
flüchtlingspolitik der politik ist das
leitprinzip dieser koalition und daran
liebe kolleginnen von der unionsfraktion
sollten auch sie sich langsam
orientieren wir brauchen weniger märz
und wir brauchen weniger demokratinnen
sie mit ihrer flüchtlingspolitik ängste
gegenüber geflüchteten schüren und
einwanderinnen als probleme die linien
überholen sie mit ihrer
flüchtlingspolitik die afd nicht rechts
damit tun sie unsere demokratie kein
gefallen und sich selbst auch nicht
lassen sie uns
stattdessen gemeinsam schritte gehen die
uns voran bringen nehmen wir einfach die
kernstücke des bund länder gipfels vom
siebten april von staatsministerin hat
erwähnt geflüchtete aus der ukraine
werden in die grundsicherung aufgenommen
letzte woche verabschiedet damit sind
die menschen in der gkv und
krankenversichert und ich möchte auch
noch mal betont ein meilenstein in der
flüchtlingspolitik in deutschland zwei
milliarden euro seitens des bundes für
länder und kommunen bei der aufnahme von
geflüchteten aus der ukraine frau b
davon eine milliarde für unterkunft und
grundsicherung und eine milliarde für
alle weiteren aufwendungen
kinderbetreuung beschulung et cetera den
aktuellen dramatischen herausforderungen
begegnen wir gemeinsam geschlossen
entschlossen wir machen und sie
schreiben masterpläne von gestern seien
sie also nicht immer dagegen machen sie
mit machen sie mit bei unserer
integrationsoffensive machen sie mit bei
einer progressiven menschenrechts
orientierten politik das ständige
schüren von ängsten dass sie betreiben
ihre spalte rey unserer vielfältigen
einwanderungsgesellschaft ist einer
christlichen partei unwürdig meine damen
und herren wir laden sie dazu ein bei
unserer zukunftsgerichteten und
pragmatischen politik in der
flüchtlingspolitik mitzumachen wie alle
geflüchteten in den blick hat mit uns
gibt es keine zwei klassen von
geflüchteten und wir werden das
flüchtlings und aufenthaltsrecht
dahingehend auch korrigieren wir werden
die ketten bildung abschaffen das wurde
schon gesagt damit schaffen wir chancen
für menschen die bereits teil unserer
gesellschaft geworden sind durch eine
praxis und lebensnahe überarbeitung der
bleiberecht und da sind wir sehr stolz
darauf durch die einführung das chancen
aufenthaltsrechts meine damen und herren
viele geflüchtete wollen arbeiten wollen
arbeiten dürfen ist aber nicht deshalb
von der unten liebe kollegin von der
union schaffen sie gemeinsam mit uns
endlich die arbeits verbote im
aufenthaltsrecht hab ein novum das muss
endlich abgeschafft werden waren stimmen
sie dagegen sie betonen unablässig die
bedeutung der familie wir machen uns
konkret stark für deren schutz statt
familien für jahre zu trennen und ihn
immer weiter hürden in den weg zu legen
wollen wir familien endlich wieder
zusammenbringen machen sie ernst und
setzen sie sich mit uns dafür einen
geflüchteten beim familiennachzug
endlich gleichzustellen und den
ehegattennachzug zu beschleunigen indem
wir den sprachnachweis vor der einreise
abschaffen meine damen und herren wir
gehen beim schutz von frauen und opfern
von menschenhandel weiter als die frau
bringen indem wir eigene und unabhängige
aufenthaltsrechte schaffen werden das
haben sie nie geschafft in den 16 jahren
in dem wir eigene unabhängige
aufenthaltsrechte schaffen her frei ich
merke an ihrer reaktion dass sie da
getroffen sind es ist die wahrheit kommt
uns liegen der schocks von besonders
wohlhabenden gruppen am herzen
verfolgung und flucht können schwere
psychische folgen nach sich ziehen und
es ist diese koalition die dafür sorgt
dass betroffene adäquate hilfe bekommen
und die psychosoziale hilfen zum ersten
mal finanziell massen aufgestockt werden
und da bin ich ministerin paust sehr
sehr dankbar für meine damen und herren
der überfall auf die ukraine hat
unendlich viel leid
zerstörung und traumatisierung gebracht
wir wissen nicht wie lange dieses grauen
noch andauern wird aber wir werden alles
tun um den verfolgt zu helfen ob hier
bei uns oder in der ukraine vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit wir lehnen den
antrag ab
filiz polat weiteres für die fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen genau im anschluss
an die debatte wird also überlegen beide
anträge der fraktionen der cdu und auch
der linken abgestimmt werden und filiz
polat hat ja gesagt die anträge von
anfang april die hätten sich überholt
marianna h da können für die afg
frauen und kindern die vor dem krieg in
der ukraine flüchten müssen geholfen
werden muss denn schließlich handelt es
sich um echte flüchtlinge die
kulturnacht dankbar und rückkehr wenig
sind etwa 90 prozent der ukrainischen
flüchtlinge sind frauen und kinder
die kulturfreunde migranten aus dem
arabischen und afrikanischen raum sind
hingegen zu 70 prozent männer
ukrainische männer stehen an der front
und bringen ihre frauen und kinder in
sicherheit merkels mit kranken stehen
vor dem sozialamt und bringen vor allem
sich in sicherheit in wirtschaftliche
sicherheit das ist der unterschied
richtig ist dass sie von der union eine
registrierung aller ukrainischen
flüchtlinge unmittelbar nach dem
grenzübertritt fordern das macht sinn
gar keine frage aber warum fordern sie
dass erst jetzt warum nicht schon 2015
als sie selbst regiert haben und warum
fordern sie das nur für ukrainische
flüchtlinge waren nicht für alle
flüchtlinge und migranten und wer soll
ausgerechnet ihnen glauben dass sie es
jetzt besser machen würden wohl nur
menschen mit stockholm-syndrom
ihre forderungen nach schutzzonen
bahnhöfen um ukrainische kinder und
frauen von menschenhändlern zu schützen
und vor anderen kriminell ist richtig
aber wo war wäre schutzzonen bisher bei
den vielen sexuellen übergriffen in
flüchtlingsunterkünften oder in der
genannte silvesternacht es ist sehr
schön dass es sich hier als law and
order partei inszenieren wir sollten die
menschen wissen dass es eben nur eine
inszenierung ist
schmerzlich erfahren musste dass eine 18
jährige ukrainerin aus angst vor dem
krieg flüchtete sie aus der ukraine nach
deutschland und nun nun flüchtete sie
aus angst vor erneuter vergewaltigung
von deutschland nach polen in einer
düsseldorfer flüchtlingsunterkunft wurde
sie von zwei männern aus nigeria und
tunesien vergewaltigt bei dem tunesier
hieß es zunächst der wäre aus dem irak
das offenbart das ganze migrations chaos
ein chaos für das sie von der cdu
mitverantwortlich sind
in polen fühlt sich diese junge frauen
und sicher also dem land das sie woche
für woche im eu parlament wegen
angeblich mangelnder rechtstaatlichkeit
mit sanktionen drangsalieren wollen aber
wenn sie frauen vor lauter angst von
deutschland nach polen flüchten wo
verstanden das unrecht in polen oder
nicht etwa doch in deutschland warum
erwähne ich das ganz einfach der
ukrainische frauen und kindern und
anderen echten flüchtlingen helfen
möchte braucht eine entsprechende
infrastruktur
doch diese infrastruktur ist ausgelastet
warum es sie ausgelastet unter anderem
weil etwa 300.000 ausreisepflichtige
ausländer nicht abgeschoben werden und
warum werden sie nicht abgeschoben weil
es hier zu jeder politische wille fehlt
der ukrainischen frauen und kindern und
anderen echten flüchtlingen helfen
möchte muss ausreisepflichtige ausländer
endlich abschieden so schafft man die
erforderlichen kapazitäten so sind
ukrainische frauen und kinder auch in
deutschland sichern also helfen wir
denen die hilfsbedürftig dankbar und
rückkehr wenig sind aber nicht gehen die
nur aus wirtschaftlichen gründen hierher
gekommen sind und ihre frauen und kinder
zurückgelassen haben angesichts des seit
2005 10 angerichteten schadens reicht
der sogenannte masterplan für
ukrainische frauen und kinder nicht aus
was wir brauchen ist eine echte
kehrtwende in der asylpolitik
umfassende kontrolle der deutschen
außengrenze lückenlose registrieren und
erfassung der identität zurückweisung
von trittbrettfahrern mit gefälschten
ukrainischen testen konsequente
abschiebung aller vollziehbar
ausreisepflichtigen dann und nur dann
haben wir die kapazitäten ukrainischen
frauen und kindern zu helfen und dann
auch nur dann wenige frauen und kinder
aber auch deutsche bürger in deutschland
wieder sicher seien vielen dank
vielen dank frau kollegin hannah kühne
nächster redner ist der kollege stephan
thomae fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident seine frau
präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
kollegen
der kriege die ukraine bestimmt
weiterhin die diskussion bei uns in der
öffentlichkeit in den letzten wochen
natürlich vor allem das thema
waffenlieferungen etwas in den
hintergrund in der rezession ist
getreten dass im inland in ganz europa
auch viel humanitäre hilfe für getötete
personen geleistet wird ja natürlich
lief nicht immer alles überall perfekt
das wird auch niemand verlangt und
erwartet haben in so einer situation die
die schnell eintritt aber ich finde doch
das verglichen mit früheren flüchtlings
krisen innerhalb weniger wochen
funktionierende abläufe bei uns im land
stattgefunden haben und deswegen wird
auch ich natürlich den vielen
ehrenamtlern an der stelle dank sache
ist es nicht einfach nur stereotypes
pflicht üben sondern ich empfinde das
wirklich so weil ja wir alle auch in den
wahlkreisen wissen was gleich dazu wird
vor ort von vielen freiwilligen
hilfsbereiten menschen die andere
menschen aus der ukraine aufnehmen aber
schon auch die vielen mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter in den städten den
gemeinden den landkreisen die ebenfalls
viele leistungen erbringt auch ihnen
muss man danken für ihren einsatz und
ich wisst schon auch betonen dass in den
letzten wochen wirklich viel geschehen
ist bei uns im land will nur ein paar
beispiele erwähnt über
113.000 ukrainische kinder und
jugendliche sind mittlerweile bei
unseren schulen eingeschult worden das
ist immens wichtig weil die kinder und
jugendlichen doch den hauptleidtragenden
gehören und jetzt alles tun müssen dass
nicht auch noch schulisch weit
zurückgeworfen werden und den anschluss
verlieren deswegen ist es ungeheuer
wichtig dass auch die
bundesbildungsministerin aufschlag war
sicher immer wieder darauf hinweist und
auch die leeren lehrer die ja oft im
zentrum der kritik stehen wirklich
vieles leisten um die diese kinder und
jugendliche auch mitzunehmen auch ihnen
gilt unser dank weil dann und herren
oder ein anderes thema das in dem antrag
er werde medizinische versorgung ab dem
ersten sechs ist es möglich das
ukrainische geflüchtete bei uns
grundsicherung erhalten was ihre
versorgungsmöglichkeiten erheblich
verbessert auch da zeigt sich doch schon
dass ich ungeheuer viel getan hat und
noch weiter tut oder weiterer punkt
zugang zum arbeitsmarkt ja viele
menschen ja so gerede kommen hoffen
jeden tag darauf dass ihr bald
zurückkehren können die werden nicht
versuchen bei dem arbeitsmarkt fuß zu
fassen aber andere tun das sehr wohl und
da öffnen wir jetzt den weg ebenfalls
über den rechtskreis wechsel dass sie in
der arbeitsvermittlung unterkommen
können bei uns im arbeitsmarkt auch das
zeigt dass ich ungeheuer viel schon
getan hat und weiterhin tut meine damen
und herren
was aber natürlich nicht heißt dass noch
viel zu tun ist natürlich das ist ganz
klar ich persönlich bin der meinung dass
wir vor allem eine gesamteuropäische
bestandsaufnahme brauchen eine
verlässliche
möglichst vollständige datenbasis ein
lagebild um zu wissen wie geht es den
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer bei uns aber
auch in polen in ungarn der slowakei in
rumänien aber nicht auch bei uns in
deutschland in frankreich in spanien in
portugal viele von ihnen werden lange
zeit bei uns in europa bleiben viele
haben persönliche bleibe wünsche weil
sie irgendwo in europa angehörige
freunde und bekannte haben wo sie schon
untergekommen sind aber wissen auch die
leistungsfähigkeit über die
möglichkeiten dieser länder in betracht
ziehen ein anderer punkt den ich für
wichtig erachte in den ersten tagen und
wochen war unser regierungshandeln
krisenmanagements in anbetracht der der
situation aber wir müssen es natürlich
gesamteuropäisch mehr und mehr
übergehend zu vorausschauendem
langfristigen entwickelt von
perspektiven und langzeit pläne niemand
weiß wie lange dieser krieg und das
geschehen noch andauert alles ist schwer
berechenbar die katastrophe inmitten
europas dauert weiter an aber wir müssen
denkbare szenarien vorbereiten und auch
dann wenn die öffentliche öffentliche
aufmerksamkeit nachlässt uns gedanken
machen wie wir den menschen die hier
bleiben wollen hier bleiben werden
perspektiven und möglichkeiten zu bieten
wir werden aber auch auf lange zeit
sowohl bei uns im land ukrainisch
stämmige als auch russisch stämmige
menschen haben und müssen die
gesellschaft und die behörden darauf
vorbereiten dass da was auch
konfliktpotenzial erwachsen kann und
müssen insbesondere auf achten dass
russisches russischsprachige menschen
sich aber über inländische medien in
russischer sprache informieren können
und nicht angewiesen seien auf inflation
aus russland und will ich als fazit
festhalten dass sie herausforderungen
vielfältig und dauerhaft bleiben werden
und ständige anpassungen erfordern
insofern ist der antrag der union auch
von anfang an nicht ganz up to date
gewesen ist es nicht geworden deswegen
werden verstehen dass wir ihnen heute
nicht zustimmen können die regierung ist
up to date und handelt nach einem
funktionierenden masterplan ich danke
ihnen
sagt stephan thomae für die fdp fraktion
jetzt haben die nächste rednerin clara
bünger wird es sein für die linke die
sprecherin für flucht politik der
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind sehr
froh über alle gesetzlichen
erleichterungen die für geflüchtete aus
der ukraine auf den weg gebracht werden
es bleibt aber die frage warum gelten
sie nicht für alle menschen die vor dem
russischen angriffskrieg viel machen es
ist nicht ganz so wie frau
staatsministerin alaba die autobahn
gerade gesagt habe es werden nicht alle
gleich behandelt die bundesregierung
schafft ein system von geflüchteten
erster und zweiter klasse für viele
dritte starterin hat das zur folge dass
sie momentan nicht wissen wie sie über
die runden kommen sollen sie wollen
einfach nur studieren oder arbeiten
warum wird ihnen das so schwer gemacht
darin abdel asis kommt aus marokko und
hat medizin in der ukraine studiert sie
haben mir berichtet dass sie nicht
versteht warum sie jetzt nicht die
andere geflüchtete aus der ukraine
einfach weiter studieren kann und ich
verstehe das ehrlich gesagt auch nicht
es macht keinen sinn beide
unterscheidungen immer dass ich jetzt
einige bundesländer selbst spezifische
lösungen überlegen hätte vermieden
werden können wenn sie die
internationalen studierenden einfach in
den schutz nach § 24 einbezogen hätten
so wie es frau feser auch ursprünglich
versprochen hatte was es braucht ist
eine bundeseinheitliche lösung
ein anderes thema bei dem die
bundesregierung hinter ihren
ankündigungen zurück bleibt ist der
umgang mit russischen deserteur
beziehungsweise kriegsdienstverweigerer
in der regierungsbefragung vor zwei
monaten hatte frau feser erklärt sie sei
hierzu auf eu-ebene in gesprächen man
wolle handeln ich habe davon aber nichts
mehr gehört es fehlen auch klare signale
zur unterstützung von oppositionellen
aus russland der spiegel berichtete von
etwa 70 personen darunter kultur und
medienschaffende und ihre familien die
sich mit einem in wenigen wochen
ablaufenden touristenvisum in
deutschland aufhalten offenbar streiten
das auswärtige amt und das bmi seit
wochen ergebnislos darüber wie ihn die
weitere aufenthalt ermöglicht werden
soll das kann doch nicht sein das bmwi
er weiß dazu auch heute morgen wieder im
innenausschuss auf die möglichkeit eines
asylantrags das hätte für die
betroffenen zufolge dass sie in ein
aufnahmelager verteilt und einem
arbeitsverbot unterliegen würden zukunft
ungewiss das ist doch kein schutz
angebot das ist eine bürokratische
verhinderung einer klaren lösung wir
machen den vorschlag dass sie auf der
innenministerkonferenz im juni eine
aufenthaltsregelung nach paragraf 23
absatz 1 aufenthaltsgesetz schaffen um
diese gruppe einen schutz in deutschland
zu bieten weiterhin problematisch ist
auch die lage für aktivistinnen die
bislang nicht aus russland ausreisen
konnten oder sich in drittstaaten
aufhalten und dringend einen sicheren
fluchtweg in die eu benötigen auch
hierzu wird seit wochen über mögliche
aufnahme regelungen gerungen aber nichts
passiert ich fordere sie auf lassen sie
den ankündigungen endlich taten folgen
handeln sie endlich hier vielen dank
fordert hierfür die linksfraktionen
deren abgeordnete klarer bünger und
sieht eben die forderungen aus dem
antrag der linken von anfang april der
hier beraten wird und dann auch im
anschluss abgestimmt diese forderungen
sind sie längst nicht erfüllt helge lind
jetzt für die sozialdemokraten er ist
der sprecher für demokratie
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
kollegen
verkünden sie haben gerade eine neue
kategorie der textform etabliert den
rassistischen slapstick genießt dafür
dankbar habe das zur kenntnis genommen
ich will dass nur noch mal wiederholen
machen muss das glaube ich deutlich
machen auch vor allem die hier im raum
zeugen sind und ein bildschirm und sonst
wo sie sprachen ja davon echten
flüchtlingen kultur nah und dankbar ich
zitiere und dann von kultur fremden
migranten nakba rassistisch geht es
nicht einen trost gibt es allerdings
gerade sitzen hier im bundestag diverse
schulklassen auf den tribünen und ich
bin mir absolut sicher dass ein großteil
der dort anwesenden mit schaudern sich
innerlich weg gewandt hat von ihrem
vortrag und diejenigen werden in den
nächsten jahrzehnten mit ihrem
wahlverhalten dafür sorgen dass die auf
dem august der vergessenheit landen wird
also die realität wird sie wieder lebt
so viel vorab geschickt von ihrem
unterirdischen beitrag kommen wir jetzt
zum antrag der cdu fraktion
ich wünschte mir aber das ist sozusagen
cdu/csu ich habe csu vergessen muss sich
richtigerweise sagen dass sie diesen
impetus und diesen drang
vulnerabilität von geflüchteten
anzuerkennen auch auf andere gruppen
ausweiteten und da wünsche ich mir auch
ein bisschen
historische redlichkeit den in der
vergangenheit habe ich diesen impetus
und diesen drang bei ihm nicht wirklich
verspürt da müssen wir doch selbst auch
und wir hatten eine koalition
miteinander müssen auch mal
selbstkritisch gucken was es uns
gelungen was nicht gelungen und ein
vorstoß massiver vorstoß zur schützt zum
schutz von personen zb
aufnahmeeinrichtung und ähnlichen ist an
ihrem widerstand gescheitert auf diese
tatsache muss man hinweisen jetzt das in
bezug nur auf die im kreml zu fordern
ist nicht schlecht aber nicht
hinreichend ist auch deswegen nicht
hinreichend weil sie sich damit dem
verdacht aussetzen der double stand und
wenn man es ganz zuspitzt auch der
bigotterie und scheinheiligkeit denn
wenn wir etwas brauchen dann brauchen
wir solche schutzkonzepte für alle
geflüchteten personen und wenn man sich
etwas in dieser republik bewegt zeigt
die situation das ist bedauerlich es ist
aber so dass viele geflüchtete aus
unterschiedlichen ländern die vor der
ukraine krise gekommen sind verbittert
sind und sagen warum haben wir nicht die
möglichkeiten erhalten und dieses feuer
und zufriedenheit glüht sie schütten
aber noch öl in dieses feuer und das
achte ich also unrichtig und nicht in
ordnung die antwort
die antwort kann dann aber im übrigen
nicht sein nicht alles mögliche und
verbesserung des systems für ukrainerin
oder creme auf dem weg zu bringen aber
sich anzugucken wie die gesamtsituation
ist wenn sie dann fordern dass wir uns
um psychosoziale belastung von
jugendlichen kümmern müssen früher
hilfen dann bitte ich sie dass zu
ergänzen dass sie ja endlich mit ihnen
mit ihrer laut unterstützung von der ich
jetzt ausgeht etwas für psychosoziale
zentren und andere institutionen machen
können die haben nicht gerade die
rückendeckung der cdu und csu weder
bundesrepublikanischen noch in cdu
geführten ländern in letzten jahren
erfahren und dann möchte ich noch etwas
sagen weil sie ja gerade zufällig artig
die registrierung hier voranbringen
neben der rechtsfrage die ist gerade
nicht zulässt also müsste man sagen sie
wollen eine neue rechtliche grundlage
sagen sie aber auch nicht dass das
heißen würde wenn das an der grenze und
grenznahe erfolgen soll das wir flächen
denken grenzkontrolle haben sonst kann
man nicht grenznahe jeden kontrollieren
wenn nicht kontrolliert wird und dann
möchte ich noch erinnern an den achter
april eine rede von herrn hoffmann im
protokoll nachzulesen
und er zitierte da ein fall aus dem
medien- und sagte dann dass es die
situation gebe dass am berliner
hauptbahnhof die bundespolizei
kontrollieren und dann ich zitiere sich
in einem zug augen shade augenscheinlich
augenscheinlich person befinden die
nicht aus der ukraine
ich habe bis zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch
nicht verstanden wie man augenscheinlich
feststellen kann ob es ihm aus der
fährte zuschauer wir verabschieden uns
kurzfristig sirene schon in der vorschau
es gibt einen gipfel treffen auf
einladung der dänischen regierung der
regierungs chefs und chefinnen von
dänemark belgien niederlanden und
deutschland in der dänischen hafenstadt
esbjerg und es wird unterzeichnet der
ausbau der gemeinsame ausbau der
windenergie ist soll eine
pressekonferenz geben unter anderem mit
bundeskanzler olaf scholz